born from primordial Stardust 4.5
billion years ago Jupiter was the solar
system's first planet and much like its
namesake the king of the ancient Roman
gods Jupiter was destined for greatness
Jupiter is the fifth planet from the Sun
and the largest planet in the solar
system at approximately 11 Earth's wide
Jupiter has twice the amount of mass as
the other planets put together but
unlike Earth and the three other
terrestrial worlds Jupiter has no solid
surface it may not even have a
traditionally solid core rather this
giant planet may have a dense liquid
center surrounded by a worldwide ocean
of hydrogen and helium gases Jupiter's
gaseous composition can be observed in
its atmosphere about 44 miles thick the
atmosphere is a canvas of stripes and
storms churning across the giant planet
their colors range between shades of
whites yellows Browns and reds all
caused by the different chemical makeup
of each area probably the most iconic
feature of Jupiter is a crimson ground
storm that's been raging for over 300
years the Great Red Spot
it's a giant swirling collection of
clouds with wind speeds of up to 400
miles per hour at least two and a half
times faster than category 5 hurricanes
floating hundreds of miles above the
storms of Jupiter are about 79 moons the
most of the eight known planets the four
largest moons were discovered by Galileo
in 1610 called the Galilean satellites
they include Io the most volcanic Li
active celestial body in the solar
system Ganymede the solar system's
largest moon even larger than the planet
Mercury in Callisto and Europa which
along with Ganymede may contain oceans
of liquid water on
their crusts Jupiter's large collection
of moons is only made possible by the
planets massive size and gravitational
pull the strongest of all the planets in
the solar system this incredible gravity
also implements the sizes of the seven
other planets during the solar system's
earliest days Jupiter being the first
planet to form attracted and destroyed
space debris that would have helped the
other planets grow in size today that
force may serve as a shield by
attracting comets and asteroids on to
Jupiter's own surface preventing them
from crashing onto inner planets like
Earth apart from the Sun Jupiter has
become the dominant figure in the solar
system thereby earning its place at the
top of the planetary heap as king
[Music]